[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles au parlement européen
c'est parti pour 30 minutes d'actualité
européenne alors que les ordonnances sur
la loi travail viennent d'être
promulguée en france pour libérer les
énergies selon les termes du président
de la république et réduire le chômage
direction l'italie il y a deux ans
maintenant les réformes du job act ont
été votées sous l'impulsion de matteo
renzi le premier ministre de l'époque
cette loi était également censé
permettre le retour à l'emploi de
milliers d'italiens deux ans après qu'en
est t'il bilan et reportages sur place
mais d'abord l'actualité alors que
l'europe se déchirent sur l'éventuelle
prolongation de l'autorisation du
glyphosate cet herbicide très utilisé
par les agriculteurs
retour sur la polémique qui déchire
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines le
parlement les états et la commission
avec amelia marghadi commercialisés par
monsanto il ya quarante ans sous la
marque roundup le glyphosate et
l'herbicide le plus utilisé au monde
mais est il ou non cancérogènes les avis
divergent
le centre international de recherche sur
le cancer une des agences de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
classé le glyphosate comme cancérogène
probable de leur côté l'agencé
européenne chargée des produits
chimiques élève sa chargée de la
sécurité des aliments ont estimé qu'il
n'y avait pas de raison de classer cette
substance comme cancérogènes pourtant la
polémique n'en finit plus d'enfler
gonflés par les révélations du journal
le monde et les monsanto peters
selon certains courriers internes de
monsanto l'entreprise aurait influencé
les résultats des expertises officiels
et les publications scientifiques sur
leurs produits
face à ces révélations le parlement
européen a souhaité entendre le
représentant de monsanto qui ont refusé
de se présenter à l'audition réaction
les eurodéputés demandent l'interdiction
d'accès au parlement au lobby liste de
monsanto et réclame une commission d'
enquête
[Musique]
alors faut-il interdire le glyphosate et
doit-on bannir les représentants de
monsanto au sein des institutions
européennes pour en débattre j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir guillaume balas
bonjour bienvenue
vous êtes député européen membre du
groupe socialiste et démocrate en face
de vous charles gorins bienvenue à vous
vous êtes vous au sein du groupe des
démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe
député européen luxembourgeois bienvenus
enfin isabelle ory bonjour vous êtes
correspondante à bruxelles pour europe 1
est la radio télévision suisse
alors dans quelques jours une nouvelle
réunion d'experts doit se tenir
justement pour déterminer si le
glyphosate doit être ré autorisé pour
dix ans ou moins
entre les experts nationaux mais pour
être complètement clair parce que
finalement ça fait des mois qu'on entend
parler de cette histoire de glyphosate
on n'avait jamais eu autant de débats et
ça va faire un truc aussi médiatique
finalement il y avait il ya eu le ddt
quoi mais qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en arrive
aujourd'hui isabelle ory à un tel
imbroglio politico médiatique sur cette
question a déjà c'est devenu un sujet
médiatique et ça c'est la grande
différence parce que avant pourquoi
s'est décidée par des experts nationaux
dans ce qu'on appelle la comitologie ce
tailleur céder aux fonctionnaires qui
décide parce que cette semaine des
politiques non c'est pas les politiques
c'est des hauts fonctionnaires de
mandater par par les gouvernements et ça
c'est parce que ce sont des
réglementations normalement technique
chaque année on autorise on renouvelle
l'autorisation pour beaucoup de produits
sans qu'ils aient de rose égard un
problème mocratique monsieur est donc
aujourd'hui ça c'est plus accepter et le
glyphosate il tombe vraiment c'est
l'exemple parfait qui montre les
difficultés le fait que le système
européen n'est plus adapté à la demande
des consommateurs l'ont vite comprendre
de savoir et envie d'être rassuré oui
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il ya une
question de confiance autour de ces
questions
guillaume balas on a beaucoup entendu
dire en fait que les la manière de
procéder de monsanto ressembler un petit
peu ou prou à celle de l'industrie du
tabac dans sa volonté en fait d'influer
sur les résultats des expertises et du
coup sur les décisions politiques est ce
que vous feriez cette analogie
oui mais qui décide c'est ça la vraie
question que j'ai le pouvoir aujourd'hui
ce ne sont pas des citoyens ça n'est pas
le parlement européen qui votent des
objections contre les ogm monsanto et
qui ne sont jamais suivies par la
commission européenne qui décide et par
d'être haussier les états c'est monsanto
monsanto à influencer considérablement
les autorités ça
iter américaine monsanto influence
considérablement les autorités
sanitaires européennes ce qu'on appelle
l'efsa ces organisations qui doivent
évaluer les risques s'appuie aujourd'hui
sur les études privées et notamment et
surtout celle de monsanto mais ça
faisait là vraiment c'est le système qui
veut exactement et donc il faut changer
absolument de systèmes ans je me lance
qu'il faut radicalement aujourd'hui
transformer tout cela on est dans une
devant un scandale absolument majeur
c'est toute la crédibilité aujourd'hui
des institutions européennes qui est en
jeu donc il faut des études
indépendantes qui soit financée par de
la recherche publique ça pose plein de
questions ça qu'on ait les moyens mais
attendez
oui on a des moments qu'on a les moyens
de cette expertise publique financée par
l'union européenne complètement
indépendante sur tous les produits qui
sont sur le marché
il faut mettre en place un système de
contrôle parlement européen quant à lui
du moins au niveau de certains de ses
membres réclament une commission
denquête promettre la clarté sur sur ce
problème mais sur quoi cette commission
d' enquête sur les agissements de
monsanto ou sur le bruit est rentré dans
le monde heures tel que défini par peu
pas par la commission et donc ce qu'on
peut faire c'est réclamé cette cette
enquête
il faut que la conférence des présidents
du parlement européen considère comme
recevable cette demande et ensuite c'est
un quart des députés qui doit trancher
en faveur mais je voulais te dire
quelque chose à propos du processus
décisionnel les états membres lorsqu'ils
n'arrivent pas à dégager une majorité
pour le maintien sur le marché du
glyphosate ce faire la commission de
trancher et c'est là où le système
européen est défaillant si on laissait
décidé les états membres seul on
trouvait pas de décor en cas d'accueil
on trouvait pas de majorité et une caire
est en fait en faveur de responsabiliser
davantage évidemment alors la dame en
vaux se cache aussi derrière la
commission parce qu'ils savent que la
commission va n'autoriser pour être
clair à isabelle ory la commission elle
elle serait pour une prolongation de 10
ans de l'autorisation du glyphosate ses
salines la commission elle est tenue par
les avis de ses agences et les deux
agences réglementaires européennes ont
dit que le glyphosate n'était pas
cancérigène donc la commission a les
pieds poings liés le problème c'est que
on dit monsanto alors faut pas être naïf
ou monsanto comme l'industrie du tabac
comme l'industrie automobile c'est pas
des associations caritatives y poussent
leurs intérêts le vrai problème c'est
pas ça le vrai problème c'est qu'on a un
système qui auquel on peut pas faire
confiance qui aujourd'hui dans la
perception
on se dit en tant que citoyen pour ses
agences et comment elles ont pris leur
décision elles ont pris leur décision en
s'inspirant de gros études
réglementaires alors qu'ils sont on me
dit on très très encadré qui coûtent une
fortune ont dit plusieurs millions
d'euros pour les études sur le
glyphosate
mais ces études sont financées par
l'industrie et ça ça jette le doute sur
tout système tu faut qu'on change le
système aujourd'hui mais est-ce que du
coup la commission européenne les états
sont prêts à financer sa mallette mais
ses amis attendent et je veux dire il ya
un moment donné où il va falloir quand
même dire à quoi sert l'union européenne
si on est là uniquement pour faire un
marché intérieur où c'est le dumping
écologique et le dumping social
au bout d'un moment les peuples vont
dire très bien on m'arrête ça sert à
rien donc l'union européenne aujourd'hui
est de se crédibiliser on dit il n'ya
pas de moyens financiers aujourd'hui sur
cette question mais enfin c'est une
vaste blague on est en train de
défiscaliser aujourd'hui à tour de bras
notamment les plus aisés de nos
concitoyens en france et en europe
on est en train d'accepter un
bing fiscale absolument hallucinant et
on nous dirait qu'on n'est pas capable
de faire ça par exemple j'ai une
proposition que toutes les taxes qui
vont être récupérés si on arrive à le
faire sur les gaffes à google puisque
enfin l'union européenne s'est
intéressée à ces sujets soient orientés
vers la recherche publique sur des
questions écologiques
voilà à quoi nous verrions de régler le
problème quoi qu'il en soit on voit bien
que il ya quand même un problème de
confiance en fait autour de ces
questions en plus monsanto donc a refusé
d'être auditionné par le parlement
européen
est-ce que c'est inédit charles goerens
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé qu'une
entreprise comme ça refuse d'être
entendu par les parlementaires
c'est pas la première fois mais c'est la
première fois que le parlement
fonctionne une entreprise qui ne veut
pas participer à cette audition
je crois que le parlement européen a
bien fait et par là même il rétablit son
autorité donc le parlement européen a du
courage je voudrais pas dire que les
pouvoirs publics européens sont
impuissants face à ce phénomène parce
que la commission arrive à faire plier
des géants comme google pour ce qui est
de la fiscalité color of the beast a
guère réussi à la personnalité de magath
the tiger cats du système central c'est
un problème de confiance
oui quand la science festive est ou
quand la science se contredit leur
politique est en désarroi alors il faut
faire en sorte qu'on ait des instances
qui sont absolument au-dessous de au
dessus de tout soupçon
et c'est ça qui peut alimenter un débat
public ce vin sur la base duquel les
états membres ou en l'occurrence la
commission peuvent prendre des décisions
le pouvoir du parlement européen en la
matière on vous l'avait dit il s'agit du
comité au logis le pouvoir du parlement
européen est purement consultatif
on peut donner des impulsions mais nous
n'avons rien à décider de ce point là en
gros c'est pas con pression
effectivement le parlement européen en
fait n'a pas voix au chapitre dans cette
histoire là on est dans une décision
finalement plus que symbolique quand on
a interdit aux lobbies de monsanto
d'avoir accès au parlement c'est bien
que les rendez vous se font en dehors du
parlement
en gros cette commission denquête c'est
quoi ces histoires de dire où nous lui
au parlement de les parlementaires ont
jugé qu'il faut aujourd'hui poser un
d'abord il faut quand même qu'on puisse
avoir les éléments d'appréciation sur le
glyphosate
donc il faut aujourd'hui aller enquêter
sur le sujet parce que ça on les a pas
c'est ce qui a bien montré l'audition ce
cas la sortie tous les députés étaient
perdus en dix ans
finalement on a deux sons de cloche
complètement différent différent comment
on fait et le deuxième aspect il faut
enquêter sur monsanto
je rappelle qu'il ya une fusion en cours
aujourd'hui bayer monsanto qui en ferait
aujourd'hui un géant qui avec une
intégration verticale en gros où je ne
vois pas comment démocratiquement
pourrait résister à la puissance de ce
monstre qu'on est en train de créer la
commission européenne fait une pause
aujourd'hui dans l' enquête sur la
fusion bayer monsanto parce qu'ils ont
demandé d un certain nombre de documents
aux deux aux deux entreprises
le parlement européen va pas faire
confiance uniquement à la commission sur
ce sujet il faut qu'on se saisisse au
journal s la commission allait quoi elle
est pétrie de conflit d'intérêts vous
parlez quoi donc moi je pense que la
commission en fait c'est pas homogène
ouais je pense qu'au sein de la
commission il ya des conflits importants
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui se bat
elle est aujourd'hui contre les lobbys
mais je pense qu'il ya une majorité
aujourd'hui de gens au sein de la
commission européenne pour qui tout est
logique de l'emploi d'abord un et au nom
de l'emploi de la lutte contre le
chômage
et bien tout est acceptable oui à une
majorité sur ces sujets ça se voit quand
je vous donne est juste un exemple on a
battu au parlement européen
la validation des ogm qui sont
résistantes au glyphosate
à chaque fois ils ont été rejetés par
parlement européen à chaque fois ils ont
été validés par la commission européenne
isabelle ory c'est ça la logique vous
êtes d'accord avec l'analyse de
guillaume balas c'est l'emploi d'abord
et à tout prix finalement ça je pense
que c'était vraiment la logique des
dernières années ouais je trouve ce qui
est de manuel barroso ce qui est
frappant c'est c'est vraiment ces
derniers mois c'est de voir que dans ce
débat qui était quand même un débat
entre les institutions et les industries
où on mettait beaucoup en avant l'emploi
la croissance sont en train d'émerger
des nouvelles forces qui avec l'opinion
publique sert que le parlement s'est par
exemple
ces ententes sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens le parlement se fait
entendre sur le glyphosate alors certes
c'est consultatif mais ça va avoir
beaucoup de poids le mag le mans va
voter une résolution la veille du vote
des experts si le parlement dit faut pas
utiliser
ne faut pas renouveler le glyphosate
forcément à faire du bruit les gens vont
me poser des questions et pourquoi
pourquoi vous votez en poupe on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe donc je trouve que
c'est en train de bouger
je serai moins pessimiste je trouve
qu'on est dans une phase où émergent où
il ya un contre-pouvoir qui est
l'opinion publique la prison en
considération de ces problèmes et c'est
en train de changer
charles grâce vous aurez le dernier mot
est-ce que c'est aussi un enjeu de
démocratie au sein de l'union européenne
un dossier comme celui ci enjeu de
démocratie et d'efficacité sur la
démocratie genou se prononcer c'est
assez unique les cas où la commission un
exécutif tranche sans être enfin le
diable devant quiconque ils ont le droit
de trancher et c'est un problème
d'efficacité
qu'est ce qu'on fait s'il ya deux vues
divergentes au sein d'un collège comme
celui de la commission qui tranche en
occurrence et c'est ça le problème
il faut prévoir des instances
d'arbitrage de mon point de vue au
niveau de la commission ça devrait être
le président ou timmons l'un des deux ou
les deux à la fois sinon et en l'absence
de telles instances arbitrales
vous avez des réunions interservices qui
ne mène nulle part et finalement c'est
qu'elle vient aussi en 3d localise dans
l'indifférence générale et nous suivrons
a bien entendu cette question dans le
cadre de la réunion qui se tient la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles alors
depuis la crise de 2008
les pays européens ont massivement un à
un réformé leurs marchés du travail
l'objectif flexibiliser pour lutter
contre le chômage de masse un mouvement
d'ampleur qui touche désormais la france
alors que les ordonnances sur la loi
travail viennent d'être promulgué
retour sur le job act votée il y a deux
ans et demi en italie censé libérer
l'accès à l'emploi son bilan est
aujourd'hui plutôt en demi-teinte
reportage de clément perreault yaël
goujon et laurence ferrai
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le poumon économique de
l'italie
la lombardie cette région pèse un tiers
du pib national
c'est ici que nous venons mesurer les
effets du job act une ambitieuse réforme
du marché du travail mis en place il y a
un peu plus de deux ans par le
gouvernement renzi pour relancer emploi
et croissance
première étape pollini cette pme produit
des jus de citron comme souvent en
italie
c'est une entreprise familiale le gérant
marco polenghi et fils du fondateur
pour lui le job act a été une petite
révolution sur les 62 salariés du site
19 ont été recrutés grâce à ce plan une
vague d'embauchés inédite dans
l'histoire de l'entreprise
le problème principal pour nous c'était
la complexité des contrats mais aussi
leur hétérogénéité
cela ne nous permettait pas d'avoir une
gestion linéaire et simple de nos
employés le droit du travail italien
était l'un des plus protecteurs pour les
salariés les licenciements impliqué des
procédures très complexes
les contrats du job act introduisent une
période d'essai de trois ans et des
droits sociaux qui s'acquiert avec
l'ancienneté de la flexisécurité donc
puisque ces contrats restent à durée
indéterminée ceux qui les ont signés
dans un contexte de crise et de chômage
élevé semble ici plutôt convaincu les
salariés
on sait que plus on travaille plus on va
sortir de la crise et on n'est plus
responsable si on a un contrat à durée
indéterminée une responsabilité dans le
sens où on est redevable par rapport à
notre employeur
sept cent mille cdi de ce nouveau type
ont été signés en italie le chômage a
reculé d'un peu moins de 2 points et la
croissance a mollement rebondit un bilan
correct mais le job act a aussi coûté
très cher pour booster ce plan le
gouvernement a accordé sur les deux
premières années d'énormes avantages aux
employeurs exonération totale de
cotisations sociales pendant un an puis
de 40 % l'année suivante
pour ses détracteurs ce plan est en fait
un grand bluff une dépense énorme
d'argent public qui aurait pu être
utilisé ailleurs et si nous regardons en
détail nous voyons que beaucoup
d'employés ont des contrats plus
précaires plus discontinues qu'ils
passent d'un contrat à l'autre avec des
salaires plus bas salariés puis basse et
la précarité
un mal lancinant nitel angelo emilia
connaissent le refrain parker leur
génération a toujours connu des
conditions de travail instable le job
act n'a rien arrangé pour eux au
contraire c'est à dire je peux le dire
avec mes mots bien sûr le plan renzi
c'est de la merde
cela a été la touche finale d'un plan de
dérégulation du monde du travail entamé
depuis plus de 15 ans en italie en 2015
angelo a signé un contrat jobs act qui a
remplacé ce que son employeur lui
faisait signer depuis trois ans mais
cinq mois plus tard il a été licencié
résultat il n'a pas touché les
indemnités correspondant à son
ancienneté réel et milliards elle est
professeur des écoles dans le public
le job act a aussi changé en profondeur
le statut des enseignants elle est
titularisée
mais n'est lié à son établissement
actuel que pour trois ans c'est son
directeur qui décidera ensuite de son
maintien ou non dans cette école et les
directeurs d'école doivent assumer une
fonction de manager
ils ont la liberté d'embauché ou de
licencier le personnel scolaire
au bout de trois ans dans une école nous
pouvons être contraint de faire des
démarches auprès d'autres directeurs et
si cela n'aboutit pas notre mutation est
décidée par un simple algorithmes
un poste à la pérennité incertaine un
salaire modeste 1300 euros par mois à
bientôt 40 ans emilie a du mal à se
projeter dans l'avenir compagnon a
également un contrat jobs act et nous
avons essayé auprès de plusieurs banques
de simuler un prêt pour acheter un
logement
à chaque fois le prêt nous a été refusé
et nous sentons aussi précaire qu'avant
et cela ne nous aide pas envisager de
former une famille complète ce que
craignent emilia et angelo c'est que le
job act ne soit un tremplin vers une
dérégulation plus globale du marché du
travail
ces hommes sont des représentants de la
patronale de lombardie nous les
rencontrons chez oh hey mr un gros
sous-traitant automobile qui fournit
ferrari et maserati pour ces gros
employeur le job act ne va pas encore
assez loin
le bac c'est le début d'un changement
plus radical du monde du travail
l'entreprise est le moteur la nourriture
de l'économie européenne et mondiale
aujourd'hui à la lumière des événements
à des phénomènes mondiaux nous devons
repenser le modèle social pour qu'ils
soient plus adapté on ne peut
redistribuer la richesse qu une fois que
la richesse des produits
le virage économique initiée avec le job
act sera validé ou sanctionner dans les
urnes au printemps prochain à l'occasion
des élections législatives
sept cent mille emplois donc créé par ce
job act près de 2.2 chômage en moins
financer donc en partie sur les deniers
publics et donc des exonérations de
charges au prix d'une grande précarité
charles gorins est ce que c'est un
exemple à suivre ce jeu back de matteo
renzi est ce que finalement c'est un peu
le coup d'une reprise de l'emploi en
italie
je crois que les succès sont indéniables
environnement il faut voir la situation
individuelle des gens qui sont victimes
objet de 17 mois le modèle qui de mon
point de vue est plus exemplaire que le
modèle italien c'est le modèle danois
gas year modèle la loi qui est basé sur
la flexibilité et la sécurité il arrive
à combiner les deux et j'entends très
peu de plaintes du côté d'un loi sur
l'application de cette loi s'inscrit
déjà dans la durée ça fait quand même
quelques dizaines d'années que les
danois connaissent ces modèles il faut
dire aussi que l'économie danoise
fonctionne mieux
j'ai une soeur qui vit on est l'italie
elle me rapportent régulièrement de la
souffrance ton fond dans son objet les
gens qui sont sans emploi ou qui sont
menacés de précarité et italiens sont à
bout de souffle
alors je crois que cet incident est
bloqué en 35 % de chômage chez les
jeunes malgré le vietnam et la craie au
sida précarité isabelle ory on a vu un
haut niveau européen que depuis 2008 en
fait ces réformes sont un petit peu
prise dans toute l'europe
alors ça a commencé par l'allemagne avec
les réformes hartz au début des années
2000 mais ça a été le cas dans le quasi
l'intégralité des pays européens
maintenant ça touche la france
on entend beaucoup dire en fait que ces
réformes sont impulsées par la
commission européenne par l'union
européenne est ce que c'est le cas alors
ces dernières années dans ce qu'on
appelle les recommandations pays c'est à
dire les recommandations que la
commission fait chaque année aux
différents pays de la zone euro est bien
effectivement pour la france y avait
sans arrêt réforme du marché du travail
alors c'est pas écrit comment il fallait
réformer le marché du travail mais c'est
clair qu'il ya une pression pour aller
dans ce sens
mais quel est l'intérêt quand on voit
guillaume balas la précarité qui est
induite en fait pas recette
flexisécurité kiné pour le coup pas le
modèle danois
même s'il voudrait tendre vers quel est
l'intérêt en fait pour les pays
européens de tendre vers ses modèles
moi je crois que si on
vêtements de constat je crois qu'on n'a
pas encore compris ce qui est en train
de se passer dans les mutations du
capitalisme est aujourd'hui partout en
occident ils sont en train de s'étendre
aujourd'hui aux pays émergents on a
pensé simplement que la mondialisation
des échanges nous mettait en concurrence
avec des pays à bas salaires et donc il
fallait baisser en fait le coût du
travail d'une manière ou d'une autre par
ce type de réforme pour être compris
d'abord c'est infini deuxièmement ça
mais surtout en compétition les pays
européens entre eux et donc ça n'accroît
pas la convergence des économies bien au
contraire
mais surtout il ya une erreur
d'analystes très importante c'est que la
réalité depuis les années 70 c'est que
la mondialisation se double d'un autre
phénomène qu'est la révolution numérique
et technologique
et quand on regarde le nombre d'heures
travaillées en occident il n'a pas
augmenté voir un peu baissé alors que la
population elle a augmenté
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya un
partage du travail sauvages c'est parce
que je travaille sauvage et bien il se
fait par la précarité il se fait par le
fait d'avoir des mini jobs
etc etc et donc si nous voulons répondre
aujourd'hui à cette question il ya deux
pistes qui sont très importantes c'est
un nouveau modèle macroéconomique au
niveau européen
on en parlait tout à l'heure basées sur
l'écologie donc des emplois durables
apparente si on transforme l'agriculture
si on transforme avec culture sacrée des
nouveaux jobs complètement différent et
une deuxième piste s'est à nouveau
système de protection sociale
effectivement qu'il prenne en compte
cela et de ce point de vue j'aimerais
faire juste une remarque on ne peut pas
faire des réformes à la hussarde du
marché du travail pourquoi ça marche et
au danemark
aussi parce qu'au danemark il y a eu
plus d'un an de négociations et dont
elle était mon profil social est donc un
compromis social qui a été pesé au
trébuchet jeunes ont fait des
ordonnances en un mois vous êtes
d'accord charles gorins il faut changer
de paradigme complètement sur cette
question de la compétitivité tout à fait
en précisant que l'europe devrait être
active à deux niveaux premièrement au
niveau des 28es sont plutôt les aides
des états membres qui devraient accepter
de transférer des compétences dans le
domaine social à l'union européenne
l'élimination de riscal et des campings
social veut et puis à dax et rossi
salissant de la globalisation
l'europe l'a subi leur baisse est de
lutter contre mais elle concerne tous
les pays du monde
et quand on voit les effets de la
globalisation est là
deux conséquences la première c'est les
différences entre les états se réduisent
par contre les inégalités à l'intérieur
des états même s'accroissent et là
l'europe ne devrait pas rester
indifférente
elle devrait prendre une initiative
notamment au niveau du g20 pour dire
essayons de faire en sorte que là c'est
que les gens tendent dans tous les pays
du monde y ait accès à la sécurité
sociale
parce que la chine lorsqu'elle doit
introduire une dimension dans domaine
social a dit on ne sera plus compétitif
donc reste à zéro nous lorsqu'on a un
problème de financement de la sécurité
sociale
si on fait un peu plus on sera plus
compétitif mais assez en sorte
d'organiser un dialogue de façon à dire
tout ce qu'on va faire va se neutraliser
va ça va resté neutre sur la
compétitivité
je crois que c'est pas impossible
j'avais d'ailleurs écrit une lettre à
madame merkel qui en sa qualité de
président du g20 auraient dû montrer sa
note du jour sur l'instant ce n'est pas
au programme on m'a répondu que la
lettre est venue trop hâtivement un
problème de consensus sur casque sur
cette question ce convoi isabelle ory
toutefois c'est que la réalité en fait
notamment en allemagne en fait elle est
très contrastée on l'a vu lors des
dernières élections on estime qu'à 17 %
de pauvres 1 13 million de personnes
contre 14% en france près de 10 % des
allemands vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté
en gros lot de facettes de tout cela
c'est la précarité et qu'est ce que peut
faire l'union européenne là dessus est
ce qu'elle a vraiment les moyens d'agir
sur ces questions financièrement elle a
pas les moyens on a vu il ya la garantie
jeunes qui est censé aider les jeunes à
trouver un emploi une formation stade
mais c'est des montants qui à l'échelle
du continent sont pas suffisants après
elle peut fixer des priorités en
insistant davantage sur l'europe sociale
elle commence à le faire mais c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une phase est alors
particulièrement france où on est on
avait le sentiment d'être en retard par
rapport aux autres par rapport aux
allemands et donc il ya cette idée de il
faut qu'on rattrape et donc on fait les
mêmes réformes que les autres finalement
c'est pas tellement poser la question
savoir si ce chemin là était toujours
valable
quand on voit justement les ordonnances
macron pour le coup elles ont plutôt été
salué à bruxelles sas qui permet en plus
de revenir un petit peu dans le concert
des nations et
de ne plus être en fait l'homme malade
de l'europe ce qu'était l'allemagne au
début des années 2000 guillaume balas
est ce que c'est à ce prix là en fait
que la crédibilité française sera
revigoré deux choses d'abord la première
moi je ne crois pas que l'europe n'a pas
les moyens je pense que les états
membres aujourd'hui ne veulent pas
donner les moyens à l'europe de faire
cela on pourrait faire un vaste plan
aujourd'hui d'investissement en europe
et s'en donner les moyens par des
ressources fiscales propres
un jeu pas quoi par exemple une taxe sur
les transactions financières au niveau
européen c'est à cet exemple sur la
question que vous me posez sur la
question ce que vous me posez quelle
illusion et je pense moi c'est mon
désaccord majeur stratégique avec le
président de la république macron c'est
si ils pensent qu'en german is an en
gros le marché du travail français ce
qui n'est pas du tout à fait la réalité
des hommes c'est un certain nombre de
protections ou le voit par exemple son
contrat de travail vont maintenant être
plus forte en allemagne qu'elle ne sont
en france mais qu'ensuite il va pouvoir
convaincre madame merkel
par exemple de faire plus en terme d'
union européenne plus en fait en termes
de transferts de souveraineté au niveau
européen alors je pense qu'ils se
trompent fondamentalement j'ai bien peur
que nous perdions sur les deux tableaux
alors je voudrais quand même qu'on est
une petite pensée pour notre collègue
maltaise qui avait écrit sur son dernier
blog sur son dernier post de blog à
14h45 une phrase choc
comme souvent il y à des escrocs ou ou
que l'on regarde maintenant la situation
est désespérée
trente minutes plus tard sa voiture a
explosé a tué sur le coup la journaliste
daphné caruana galicia qui n'avait cesse
depuis des années de condamner la
corruption endémique à malte jusqu'au
plus haut sommet de l'état dont des
accusations qui visait le premier
ministre maltais joseph muscat qui avait
dû convoquer des élections anticipées
suite à ce scandale avant d'être réélu
malte pays entrés dans l'union
européenne en 2004
selon la presse maltaise c'est un
assassinat politique
votre réaction que mesk gt gt
catastrophé par cela je pense que
malheureusement oui la corruption la
mafia lisation j'allais dire de l'europe
est en route sur bien des sujets et cela
pose maintenant une question là aussi à
l'union européenne mais qui est toujours
la même
est-ce qu'on veut exister ou pas en tant
que tel faut avoir un parquet européen
sur les questions financières je crois
que c'est extrêmement important il faut
avoir une autorité sociale
européenne le président juncker l'a
proposé et espérons qu'elle va se
concrétiser pour lutter contre le
dumping social faut avoir les moyens de
lutter contre ceux qui font de l'évasion
fiscale bref il faut que au niveau
européen et bien on fédéralise
aujourd'hui un certain nombre d'actions
pour faire en sorte de pour poursuivre
les assassins qui ont fait cela charles
gorins il faudrait plusieurs plus de
moyens à l'europe
on voit d'ailleurs l'instauration d'un
procureur européen pour notamment pour
lutter contre la fraude au budget
européen n'est pas partagé par tout le
monde
donc il faut que tous les états
apportent leur contribution pour que
justice se fasse en la matière isabelle
ory c'est étonnant que on avait beaucoup
entendu parler notamment la roumanie sur
les questions de corruption
malte finalement c'est quelque chose
d'assez inédit ça a été un peu compliqué
parce que malte avait la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne ya pas
si longtemps alors du coup je pense que
c'était un petit peu et tout fait ces
conversations mais là ce qu'est ce qui
est quand même frappant c'est que ça se
passe à malte et tout le monde en parle
et chaussons voilà c'est terrible ce qui
s'est passé mais sauf une certaine forme
de réconfort à voir qu'il va y avoir un
débat au parlement européen la semaine
prochaine sur ce qui s'est passé il ya
eu des mots à la commission européenne
donc c'est que ça c'est hors pays' et
ces questions là et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose
kiki qu'on peut saluer merci à vous de
nous avoir éclairé sur tout et c'est sur
tous ces sujets c'est la fin de cette
émission mais pas de panique vous pouvez
la revoir en replay et à l'envi sur nos
sites
lcp point fr publicsenat.fr et rtbf.be
la semaine prochaine c'est ahmed tazir
que vous retrouvez à ma place depuis
bruxelles très belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]